well I woke up this morning and I said
to myself sir we should really do a show
today there's a lot going on and so here
we are that's the context in which
today's program is is being produced One
programming note dozens of people
writing to me uh breathlessly you could
tell even though though it was written
text that people were breathless saying
David when is your Lex Friedman
appearance coming out I don't know the
answer but I Lex said it would be three
or four days from when we filmed it
earlier this week so I would guess by
the end of this week but I don't know
and I don't have any control over it but
I'm as I'm as eager to take a look at it
as some of the other folks in the
audience are so we'll know about that
very very soon all right listen I've
been waiting for this and it is now
happening Republicans right Wingers Maga
types Stephen Crowder and others are now
coming after what we call no fault
divorce which essentially translates to
they want to force women to have to stay
married unless they can give what some
consider an acceptable reason for why
they should be allowed to get divorced
what on Earth am I talking about let's
backtrack and let's set it up I had no
plan to talk about right-wing content
creator Stephen Crowder's divorce on the
podcast there's really just no reason to
talk about it I don't know there's
nothing particularly newsworthy about it
except when I watched his brief
explanation of the personal trouble that
he's having and including this very
contentious divorce he seemed to sort of
bemoan the fact that his wife can just
say hey I want a divorce and it's called
no fault divorce you don't have to prove
that someone cheated or whatever
uh to justify the divorce you're just
allowed to say I don't want to be in
this marriage anymore and in the video
that Stephen Crowder
um put out about this he seemed to be
sort of suggesting that that's a problem
that that's not okay his wife maybe
should be forced to stay married to him
and he's not the only one who feels this
way let's take a listen this is the
video from I guess now it's been about a
week since this news broke to the extent
that it's news uh I have been living
with a proverbial boot on my neck for
going on years now
uh since 2021 I've been living through
what has increasingly been a horrendous
divorce now let me say on the outset to
be clear there is no infidelity any kind
of physical abuse at all on either side
and no this was not
my choice my then wife decided that she
didn't want to be married anymore
and in the state of Texas that is
completely permitted
it's permitted it's allowed as crazy as
it is
you're just allowed to say I don't want
to be married anymore and I can't
control that so this is now building
into a bigger Story and there's a very
interesting Rolling Stone article the
next front in the Republicans war on
women no fault divorce Stephen Crowder
is part of a growing right-wing chorus
calling for an end to Modern divorce
laws and the article explains and you
can check it out Stephen Crowder is
getting a divorce he says it's not his
choice he says his wife is just allowed
to do it and the article says Crowder's
emphasis on the state of Texas makes it
sound like the Lone Star State is an
outlier but all 50 states in the
District of Columbia have no fault
divorce laws on the books laws that
allow either party to walk away from an
unhappy marriage without having to prove
abuse infidelity or other misconduct
Republicans are now unsure whether this
is something that they actually want and
the article goes on to say uh
like the Crusades against abortion and
contraception making it more difficult
to leave an unhappy marriage is about
control Crowder's home state could be
the first to eliminate it if the Texas
Republican party gets its way last year
the Republican party of Texas added
language to its platform calling to an
end to no fault divorce this is another
way to potentially control women that's
what this is fundamentally about no
fault divorce is a legal process which
basically just means you can end a
marriage without having to prove that
any spouse is at fault for the breakdown
of the marriage and the history of no
fault divorce in the United States goes
back to the early 20th century but it
really wasn't until the 1970s that no
fault divorce had widespread acceptance
and before you had no fault divorce yeah
I I sound like Trump many people don't
know this
a lot of people have no reason to think
about this but before there was no fault
divorce
divorce laws in the U.S were based on
fault and what that meant is in order to
be granted a divorce in order to be
allowed to get a divorce one spouse had
to prove that the other spouse was at
fault for the failure of the marriage
and often it was adultery
cruelty some kind of Abandonment like
they basically left already anyway
sometimes insanity or or you know what
we might call mental illness and then in
the 60s and 70s states started to
rightfully reconsider that and say Hey
you know maybe people in the same way
that they can choose to get married
should just be allowed to choose to no
longer be married anymore and California
was the first to pass no fault divorce
in 1969 and then by the end of the 1970s
Most states had done the same thing the
really important thing to understand
here aside from what I believe to be the
obvious logic that you shouldn't have to
make a case to be allowed to get
divorced you should just be able to say
I don't want to be married anymore it's
worth mentioning that no fault divorce
significantly improved the lives of
women as well as children in many
situations by giving them greater legal
protections and more Equitable outcomes
in divorce proceedings now there is
you'll have the men's rights activists
who love to say uh men routinely and and
sort of systematically get screwed over
when it comes to custody in divorce
proceedings and it's unfair and all
these different things I consider that
to be a different issue that can be
discussed on its merits but understand
that prior to the introduction of no
fault divorce particularly because it
was during an era where women were
statistically less likely to work or if
they work they were statistically likely
to to be earning less money than the
husband in a heterosexual marriage they
were more likely to be dramatically
disadvantaged and controlled by the lack
of no-fault divorce and so no no fault
divorce as obvious as it is to many of
us and as standard as it is in so many
other Western developed Nations it
actually was a really significant change
uh and and liberating to some degree
[Music]
providing additional rights to many
women as it became more common during
the 1970s so it's not a surprise given
that Republicans love policy
that allows women to be controlled let's
control what women can do with their
bodies let's control medically Etc given
all of that it's not a surprise that
they found yet another issue on which
they want to go back to the 1950s and
again that's quite literally what we're
talking about this was the law of the
land in the 1950s started changing 69
into the 70s I had it an inkling when I
saw the Crowder video
they're gonna go after this no-fault
divorce and now that is in and of itself
becoming a bigger story horrifying stuff
but it is the party it is the movement
of going back to the 1950s